[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend es ist schwieriger geworden
in unserer welt für fakten sie haben
probleme noch durchzudringen durch
misstrauen und querdenken de
verschwörungs mythen aber fakten sind
störrisch sie gehen nicht weg wenn man
sie leugnet die korona kennziffern auch
heute wieder auf einen neuen rekordwert
gestiegen machen offenbar eindruck
menschen ändern ihre einstellung und
ihre entscheidungen an seinem stern
berichtet dass sich das zeigt an den
impfstellen
im zweiten virus winter in deutschland
muss man viel geduld mitbringen und
vielleicht auch eine eigene warme
sitzgelegenheit göttingen niedersachsen
langes warten auf die anti kowitz
spritze auch gertrud windbeutel ist
hergekommen
weil wir unseren sohn
großer andrang kleines ins team
an dieser station in göttingen werden im
schnitt 150 spritzen verabreicht pro tag
vor nicht allzu langer zeit stand genau
hier noch das große im zentrum der stadt
1500 menschen konnten damals täglich
drankommen die schließung ein
schnellschuss eine schlechte
entscheidung sagen ärzte und
einsatzkräfte
die politischen entscheidungen sind ja
in den letzten anderthalb jahren leider
sehr oft der wirklichkeit hinterher
gehinkt und nicht immer von weitsicht
geprägt
ich persönlich halte es für einen großen
fehler dass man die zentren geschlossen
hat wenig weitsicht viel hin und her so
die kritik irgendwie tempo reinbringen
in die impfkampagne sollen jetzt immer
mehr mobile teams wie hier in
braunschweig im shoppingcenter
sogenannte pop up impfstellen vor oder
nach dem geschenke kaufen soll hier die
pandemie bekämpft die spritze an mann
und frau gebracht werden
häufig kommen wir hier schon um halb
zehn reihen und wobei wir um 10 anfangen
und die schlange ist quasi schon um die
100 meter lang amra die isn hat
vergangene woche das gruppe kommen fürs
impfen im einkaufszentrum über nacht
wurden camping zelte aufgestellt in
denen vor allem menschen sitzen die den
booster schutz wollen aber nicht nur
erstimpfungen sind ab und zu auch dabei
also eigentlich wollte ich mich nicht
impfen lassen weil ich angst habe aber
man kommt jetzt mehr druck um also man
hat ja ich keine wahl mehr weil man
kontinuums bereit man kann nichts mehr
machen und dann deswegen habe jetzt
gesagt weiß auch neu geimpft frisch
gepostet immobilen im zelt auch so soll
die vierte welle bekämpft werden das
jedenfalls ist die hoffnung im zweiten
virus winter in deutschland
und das muss gelingen denn die lage hat
sich sehr schnell zum schlechteren
geändert das bedeutet die maßnahmen
müssen besser werden wirksamer
übermorgen soll der bundestag noch
einmal das infektionsschutzgesetz
anpassen in einer eigenartigen situation
noch steht die alte regierung in der
verantwortung
geschäftsführend die wahrscheinliche
zukünftige ampel regierung hat aber
schon jetzt die mehrheit im bundestag
wenn es um gesetze geht wäre es wenig
sinnvoll ihr im wege zu stehen man
stimmt sich also ab christian von
rechenberg überwege raus aus der steilen
aufwärtskurs dabei stehen zwei punkte
wohl schon fest keine lockt downs mehr
die für alle gelten also auch für
geimpfte und mehr verantwortung mehr
entscheidungsmacht geht an die länder
und die nutzen das heute haben einige
ihre corona regeln schon verschärft
deutschland muss sich entscheiden immer
öfter den weg weisen die länder kneipen
hotels kinos öffentliche veranstaltungen
künftig nur noch offen für geimpfte und
genesene mancherorts auch sport
einzelhandel oder friseure zweig kommt
oder gilt verschärft etwa in hamburg
thüringen nrw baden-württemberg
die lage ist ernst sie ist sehr ernst
wir haben so viele infektionen wie nie
zuvor mit dramatisch steigender tendenz
es gelte die kliniken zu schützen wo
ärzte und pflegende in sorge sind ob sie
der vierten welle standhalten wir werden
jedem menschen helfen können und wir
werden auch jeden menschen helfen aber
es wird keine wohnortnahe versorgung
mehr abgesichert werden können und
letztlich auch werden wir irgendwann an
die stelle kommen wo entschieden werden
muss dass in andere bundesländer mit
verteilt wird einige bundesländer gehen
noch weiter wachsen etwa oder berlin
planen zu den verschärfungen zweig plus
also zugang nur für genesen und
geimpften mit aktuell negativen test
oder mit maske auf abstand oder alles
zusammen man muss zeit gewinnen ich
appelliere an alle sich impfen zu lassen
und die impfmöglichkeiten die wir haben
anzunehmen wir sind in so einer
privilegierten situation
anders als in anderen ländern haben wir
mehrere impfstoff in ausreichender zahl
es ist doch fatal so ein angebot nicht
anzunehmen in bayern nehmen sie es an
schlangen vor den im stationen einige
stehen hier notgedrungen in bayern gilt
seit heute zweig dem ministerpräsidenten
genügt das nicht was ist braucht es zwei
die flächendeckend in deutschland es
braucht eine klare booster empfehlung
die schon bereits ab dem fünften monat
stattfindet wir brauchen eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
auch das muss rasch verabschiedet werden
umstritten rechtlich womöglich tragbar
experten verweisen auf bestehende
nachweis und in pflichten in einigen
berufen zudem würden gerichte die
kritische lage berücksichtigen ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass eine solche
impfpflicht bestand vor gericht haben
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
ein solcher im gesetzesentwurf am
donnerstag durch den bundestag und am
freitag durch den bundesrat gehen dann
ist wäre das sicherlich innerhalb von
einer woche umsetzbar die ampel
koalition offen für impfpflicht
bestimmter berufsgruppen will dazu in
den kommenden wochen ihren plan forscht
beim koalitionsvertrag hatten spd grüne
und fdp schneller der könnte schon
nächste woche fertig sein
unterdessen hat die cdu eine vielleicht
unmögliche aufgabe zu vergeben die
partei wieder aufrichten und war
siegfähig machen als vorsitzender das
bewerberfeld in reihenfolge des
posteingangs helge braun demnächst
ehemaliger kanzleramtsminister schon von
amts wegen
nachlassverwalter der ära merkel norbert
röttgen gescheitert beim ersten anlauf
um den parteivorsitz davor gescheitert
als spitzen spitzenkandidat in nrw und
auch schon gescheitert als
umweltminister im bund friedrich merz
schliesst sich zweimal gescheitert als
parteivorsitz kandidaten in grauer
vorzeit von angela merkel vom
fraktionsvorsitz verdrängt einer soll
aus verfall wieder aufstieg machen den
trend umkehren schnell nächstes jahr
sind vier landtagswahlen und im 3 davon
kann die union eine landesregierung
verlieren sie muss mindestens mal die
wähler zurückholen die sie früher mal
hatte aber das war halt früher und heute
ist früher auch nicht mehr wie früher
heute trat der an der vom lebensalter
her am tiefsten im frühjahr verwurzelt
ist und trotzdem favorit mathis feldhoff
berichtet
da wartet er auf den punkt genau
musikeinsatz unterstützt durch eine
regieanweisung fein orchestriert vor
schillernder kulisse und jeder menge
fans kündigt friedrich merz am
nachmittag seine dritte kandidatur als
cdu vorsitzende an wir müssen neue
antworten auf neue fragen geben märz bin
ich die von gestern wirken schon seit
seiner ersten kandidatur von vor drei
jahren kämpft er mit diesem image dem
image des konservativen der die achse
der cdu verschieben will es wird mit mir
hier keinen rechtsruck in der union
geben es wird keine achsen verschiebung
in der union geben mit mir soll es ein
klares profil geben das team das er
präsentiert ist viel kleiner als mancher
erwartet hat ein neuer generalsekretär
und dessen künftige stellvertreterin
beide eher unbekannte im universum der
union christina stumpf soll künftig die
kommunalpolitiker abbilden und mario
czaja den sozialen flügel wir haben eine
immer größere schere von arm und reich
das kann uns nicht kalt lassen und die
cdu muss die soziale frage stärker ins
auge märz vielleicht größter konkurrent
war schon letzte woche vor kameras
getreten norbert röttgens auftritt ist
nicht ganz so bunt nicht ganz so
großspurig auch er präsentiert mit
franziska hoppermann eine neue
bundestagsabgeordnete als
generalsekretärin
röttgen greift märz nicht direkt an aber
jeder weiß was er meint die mitte der
gesellschaft die muss ich in der mutter
muss die cdu sein das ist unser standort
dieser standort muss sich in der person
des vorsitzenden ausdrücken auch röttgen
hat die schwachstelle der union beim
sozialen ausgemacht
daraus folgt dass wir als cdu stärker
wieder probleme themen aus der
perspektive normaler menschen betrachten
müssen der dritte kandidat hat eine
öffentliche vorstellung bisher versäumt
kanzleramtsminister helge braun wurde
letzte woche von seinem kreisverband
gießen nominiert seine ideen hat er in
einem brief zusammengefasst ich spüre
eine große sehnsucht dass wir klarer
definieren was die vorstellungen und
konzepte der cdu deutschland sind brown
sei kein merkel kandidat sagen seine
unterstützer im gegenteil also so viel
verdient wie sie in der regierung hat
die parteiarbeit hat sie schleifen
lassen das sieht der sehr klar und ich
glaube mit ihm würde die cdu sich nach
innen hin am stärksten ändern einer muss
sich ab nun sorgen machen fraktionschef
brinkhaus konnte heute mit ansehen wie
friedrich merz sich die kandidatur zum
oppositionsführer offenhielt auch darin
unterscheidet er sich von seinen
konkurrenten
wahlkampf folgt nachrichten von gundula
gause die gaspipeline nord stream 2 wird
vorerst nicht in betrieb gehen können
zwar ist die ostseepipeline
fertiggestellt aber die
bundesnetzagentur hat das verfahren zur
freigabe aus formalen gründen auf eis
gelegt zunächst müsse die betreiberfirma
nach deutschem recht organisiert werden
heißt es von der regulierungsbehörde
der gaskonzern gazprom dringt auf eine
schnelle zertifizierung um noch größere
mengen an russischem gas über
deutschland nach europa liefern zu
können kritiker warnen vor einer
wachsenden abhängigkeit von russland in
dem langwierigen streit zwischen eu und
polen über das polnische justizsystem
gerät warschau weiter unter druck der
europäische gerichtshof urteilte die
machtfülle des polnischen
justizministers der auch
generalstaatsanwalt ist sei unvereinbar
mit eu-recht zugleich fordern die fünf
fraktionen im eu-parlament dass die
kommission milliardenschwere corona
hilfen für polen zurück hält bis
warschau die eu regeln der
rechtsstaatlichkeit wieder einhalten mit
einem weiteren urteil will der bgh auch
ungarn zur beachtung von eu-recht
zwingen die richter urteilten dass die
regierung in budapest mit einem gesetz
die rechte von asylbewerbern und ihren
unterstützern in ungarn einschränke in
der eu aber hätten asylbewerber das
recht sich rat und hilfe zu suchen dass
die orban regierung dies unter strafe
stelle sei nicht vereinbar mit eu-recht
das österreichische parlament hat den
weg für korruptionsermittlungen gegen
den früheren kanzler sebastian kurz frei
gemacht einstimmig beschloss der
zuständige ausschuss des nationalrates
die aufhebung seiner immunität kurz war
anfang oktober zurückgetreten wegen des
verdachts der untreue gegen ihn und
einige seiner mitstreiter mit geschönten
und aus steuermitteln finanzierten
umfragen soll kurz aufstieg zum kanzler
unterstützt worden seien kurz weist alle
vorwürfe zurück
im grenzgebiet zwischen armenien und
aserbaidschan ist es ein jahr nach
kriegsende trotz eines vereinbarten
waffenstillstandes zu schweren gefechten
zwischen den verfeindeten
kaukasusrepubliken gekommen ein
armenischer soldat wurde getötet mehrere
auf beiden seiten verletzt wie seit
beginn des konfliktes ende der 1980 er
jahre beschuldigen sich beide seiten
beide staaten gegenseitig der aggression
nach angaben aus moskau wurden die
aktuellen kämpfe nach einem telefonat
von präsident putin mit armeniens
regierungschef machine jahren beendet
die nachrichten heute zeigen wie sich
der östliche horizont von eu und nato
verdüstert auf vielfältige weise
rechtlicher ärger im eigenen lager mit
polen und ungarn kämpfe im gar nicht so
fernen nordkaukasus die ukraine die
nicht zur ruhe kommt und nicht in ruhe
gelassen wird und die wieder
hochkochenden alten konflikte auf dem
zersplitterten balkan es wird
ungemütlich berichtet unser nato
korrespondent in brüssel aus allen
richtungen sogar von oben ganz so
ein funkspruch weckt die astronauten auf
der weltraumstation iss am frühen morgen
die nasa zentrale meldet sich wir wurden
informiert über die zerstörung eines
satelliten ihr müsst euch in sicherheit
überstunden müssen die astronauten hier
bilder ihrer ankunft in die angedockten
raumschiffe russland habe im rahmen
eines tests einen satelliten
abgeschossen der entstandene schrott
drohe jetzt die weltraumstation zu
treffen die iss blieb unversehrt unten
auf der erde ist der ärger trotzdem groß
das war eine rücksichtslose tat von
russland das muss uns sorgen machen denn
es zeigt dass russland jetzt neue
waffensysteme entwickelt die satelliten
abschießen können
russlands außenminister lavrov
dementiert postwendend nicht den
satelliten abschuss wohl aber die
einschätzung dass der schrott eine
gefahr darstelle aus sicht vieler im
westen da war passt die aktion ins bild
einer serie an machtdemonstrationen
durch russlands präsident putin da sind
groß angelegte medizin übungen wie hier
im september von belarussischen und
russischen truppen da sind aktuell
ungewöhnliche truppen aufmärsche in der
nähe der ukraine bilder die wir an
bekanntes muster wirken begann nicht so
russlands annexion der krim vor sieben
jahren
die russischen aktivitäten an der grenze
zur ukraine erinnern in der tat an 2014
und jetzt geht es darum deutlich zu
machen dass dieser alarmierenden lage so
nicht akzeptiert werden kann was
akzeptiert der westen wie geschlossen
reagiert er wirklich das wird gerade
auch hier getestet an der tollen spieler
russischen grenze wo es heute so zeigen
es bilder der polnischen polizei zu
heftigen auseinandersetzungen kommt auf
der einen seite polnische
sicherheitskräfte mit wasserwerfern auf
der anderen migranten mit steinen
menschen die das belarussische regime
vermutlich mit billigung putins hierher
geschickt hat an die grenze eines landes
das gerade selbst mit manchen
europäischen werten im konflikt stimmt
es gibt große verwirft nisse innerhalb
der europäischen union
polen hat einen rechtsstreit verfahren
laufen mit der europäischen union das
heißt was man macht ist das was man
eigentlich 2014 seitdem überfälle krim
eigentlich versucht hat nämlich den
westen zu spalten es ist diese lage in
der noch kanzlerin merkel gestern abend
zum telefon greift und 50 minuten lang
mit dem belarussischen machthaber
lukaschenko spricht ein diktator den die
eu nicht anerkennt den die
realpolitikerin merkel damit so sagen
kritiker aufwertet ich finde dass das
ein falsches signal war ausgerechnet
jetzt nach diesem erpressungsversuchen
direkt kontakt und gespräch mit
lukaschenko zu suchen ob oben im weltall
oder unten in der kälte des
belarussischen grenzgebietes der
schlüssel für die lösung dürfte nicht in
minsk liegen wir in moskau
vor bald zweieinhalb tausend jahren hat
der griechische stratege und historiker
thukydides eine lehre aus den großen
kriegen seinerzeit gezogen aus dem
aufstieg athens und dem niedergang
spartas so etwas schrieb er geht nicht
ohne gewalt ab das war seine these wer
will kann im lauf der weltgeschichte
seitdem belege dafür finden unumstritten
ist die these von der verheerenden
todesfalle nicht für die welt hängt
gerade viel davon ab dass es den usa und
china gelingt diesen alten griechen zu
widerlegen da hat er auch keine ahnung
dass staatenlenker heute selbst in
zeiten einer seuche mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit um den halben
erdball herum miteinander reden und sich
in die augen schauen können um zu finden
worauf es ankommt gemeinsame
notwendigkeiten notwendige
gemeinsamkeiten so geschehen in der
letzten nacht deutscher zeit claudia
bates berichtet ausforschung
eingangs gleich mal freundlichkeiten als
fiebersenkendes mittel beiden erinnert
an frühere begegnungen
sie nennt ihn seinen alten freund als ob
einen bitteren wettstreit fechten die
beiden aus einem von dem globales wohl
oder wehe abhängt hier soll es darum
gehen diese rivalität verantwortungsvoll
zu gestalten
es liegt in unserer verantwortung
sicherzustellen dass der wettbewerb
zwischen unseren ländern nicht in einen
konflikt mündet beabsichtigt oder
unbeabsichtigt
einfacher geradliniger wettbewerb
einfach dabei geht es um globale führung
es geht um wirtschaft und handel es geht
um den kampf der systeme
biden will beweisen dass die
freiheitliche demokratie nicht chaos ist
wie china dies sieht er musste in
chinesen der welt und zu einem eigenen
land zeigen dass demokratie noch
funktioniert china will sein image
aufpolieren kritisiert von den usa für
die verfolgung der uiguren für die
niederschlagung der demokratiebewegung
in hongkong hier will die bereitschaft
zu friedlicher zusammenarbeit zeigen
wir müssen jeweils unseren teil der
internationalen verantwortung schultern
und zusammenarbeiten um das vornehme
anliegen des weltfriedens vor anzufangen
doch beim handel herrscht kein frieden
sondern krieg und einer lösung sind
beiden und hier im gespräch nicht näher
gekommen im streit um taiwan hat china
den militärischen druck erhöht sie
sprach auch jetzt wieder von
wiedervereinigung also eroberung beiden
betonte kürzlich in einer
bürgersprechstunde überraschend eine
verteidigung spricht für taiwan
entsetzen in china auch hier keine
annäherung
natürlich gibt es noch probleme aber die
chinesische mauer wurde nicht an einem
tag gebaut und man kann sie auch nicht
an einem park niederreißen es braucht
zeit schritt für schritt aber ich sehe
positive schritte und ich hoffe davon
gibt es dann noch mehr in der zukunft
die kommunikationswege offenhalten
weitere eskalation verhindern darum ging
es stabilisierung
von beiden nicht mehr viel zu china
heute er muss probleme im eigenen land
lösen auch um für den internationalen
wettbewerb gut aufgestellt zu sein
hierzulande gibt es mal gute nachrichten
aus der wirtschaft
mitten in der vierten welle der pandemie
gibt es erstaunlich gute meldungen aus
der wirtschaft im euroraum die hat im
sommer kräftig zugelegt und damit in
diesem quartal sogar das wachstum in den
usa übertroffen trotz aller
lieferprobleme und der anziehenden
inflation frank bethmann wie gut kommt
denn europas wirtschaft im
internationalen vergleich durch die
pandemie mehr tatsächlich täuscht der
erste eindruck ein wenig insgesamt war
das ein ordentliches wachstum im letzten
quartal ja aber es hätte auch noch ein
bisschen besser sein können wären da
eben nicht doch jene lieferengpässe
gewesen lieferengpässe mit denen auch us
unternehmen kämpfen die aber inzwischen
noch ganz andere schwierigkeiten haben
die finden bei einer konjunktur unter
volldampf nämlich kaum noch
arbeitskräfte auch das dämpfte das us
amerikanische wachstum im jetzt dritten
quartal deutlicher ein als jenes in der
eurozone trotzdem hängt die eurozone
noch immer hinterher ist noch nicht
wieder auf vorkrisenniveau anders die
usa und china deren volkswirtschaften
die korona scharte längst ausgesetzt
haben trotz der zuletzt erfreulichen
entwicklung in einigen euro ländern
schlagen sich die usa und china
insgesamt also besser und vor allem sie
reden wieder miteinander die signale vom
video gipfel sorgten auch hier für
entspannung was nicht zuletzt den dax
beflügelte das deutsche leitbarometer
erklimmt mit 16.000 248 punkten das
nächste neue allzeithoch die serie von
neuen bestmarken reist also nicht ab und
man fragt sich hier mittlerweile schon
wohin soll das eigentlich alles noch
führen ich fand bethmann vielen dank in
mehreren bundesländern hat es heute
warnstreiks im öffentlichen dienst
gegeben vor allem
universitätskliniken hochschulen und
behörden wurden bestreikt die
gewerkschaft verdi hatte dazu aufgerufen
um den druck im aktuellen tarifstreit zu
erhöhen unter anderem gab es auch in der
uniklinik hannover einen warnstreik die
notfallversorgung soll trotzdem
gewährleistet gewesen sein verdi fordert
fünf prozent mehr gehalt mindestens aber
150 euro monatlich
zum sport die italienische
fußball-nationalmannschaft hat vier
monate nach ihrem em-sieg die direkte
qualifikation zur wm 2022 in katar
verpasst nach dem 0 zu 0 gegen
nordirland gestern geht es nun in
schwierige playoffs hier warten starke
gegner wie portugal schweden und polen
auch 2018 fand die wm ohne italien statt
bei den atp finals in turin hat
tennisprofi alexander zverev seinen
gruppenspiel gegen titelverteidiger
daniel mit wir verloren damit muss der
hamburger nun um den einzug ins
halbfinale der acht jahresbesten kämpfen
im zweiten satz konnte der
weltranglisten dritte zverev wegen eines
fußfehlers von medwedew noch aufholen
aber nach gut zweieinhalb stunden gewann
der us open champion mit vegf
mittlerweile ein angstgegner schweres
denn es war seine fünfte niederlage in
folge gegen den russen
deutsches strafgesetzbuch von 1872
paragraf
175 stellte unter tierisch grausamer
überschrift homosexuelle handlungen
zwischen männern unter strafe die nazis
haben die vorschrift als werkzeug
benutzt um homosexuelle zu opfern ihrer
vernichtungsfeldzug gegen alles andere
zu machen wie lange diese vorschrift nur
in kleinen zögernden schritten immer mal
wieder um einige extreme gemindert nach
der in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
nach dem weltkrieg wirksam war
100000 männer vor strafgerichte brachte
das ist die handlung des beachtenswerten
films große freiheit der diese woche
erscheint nadia nasa hat ihn schon
gesehen
1968 hans lied männer darf das aber nur
heimlich der stadt beobachtet filmten
mit zum beispiel auf öffentlichen
toiletten denn sex unter männern wird in
westdeutschland mit gefängnis bestraft
praktiken
widernatürlich und sucht paragraf 175
gegeben dass fremden dieses
wechselseitige onanie diesmal bekommt
hans zwei jahre für ihn nichts neues
schon die nazis haben ihn ins kz
gesperrt und ab 1945 muss er immer
wieder in den strafvollzug denn der
paragraf 175 bleibt wir wollten seine
biografie seine geschichte und seine
seiner knastaufenthalt ist zeigen weil
die weil das gefängnis war so die
konstante in seinem leben dass man das
draußen aus spart und sagt das sind
eigentlich die wichtigsten stationen
weil ihm ihr letztlich das leben
verboten wurde also wenn man menschen
beziehungen verbietet verbietet das
leben 1945 nach
anfänglicher ablehnung wird der
österreichische zellengenosse viktor zu
seiner wichtigsten stütze
viktor sitzt eine lange strafe ab
totschlag hans hat gerade erst das kz
überlebt zwischen den ungleichen
gefangenen wächst eine stille
vertrautheit
einige jahre später treffen sie sich
wieder hans ist zurück im knast er kann
das lieben einfach nicht lassen
liebe es glaube ich etwas viel größeres
und damit habe ich mich versucht
auseinanderzusetzen was bedeutet es zu
lieben
in gefangenschaft und
wie funktioniert für mich als hans dann
die freiheit weil die freiheit ja auch
ein ganz absurden orten möglich sein
denn hans wer sich auch im gefängnis
nicht vorschreiben lassen wen er zu
lieben hat
schon
miteinander verloren stehen bleiben
und zahlt dafür einen hohen preis große
freiheit erzählt eindrücklich von dem
schicksal unzähliger homosexueller von
staat und gesellschaft kriminalisiert
richtung blieb natürlich lange zeit und
der biograf selbst ist erst sowohl in
deutschland als auch in österreich 94
erst abgeschafft worden wirklich der
staat wollte eigentlich über jahrzehnte
nicht einsehen dass er da gegen
menschenrechte verstoßen hat dir
eigentlich schützen sollte
ein sinnlos verpasstes leben hinter
gittern fantastisch gespielt von franz
rogowski völlig zurecht österreichs
kandidat für den auslands oscar
den auslands oscar gewinnen solche filme
gelegentlich das war es von uns und um
mitternacht meldet sich jena sein könnte
mir mit unserem heute schon mal updates
[Musik]
genannt das hier ist ein vierer druck
fällt es besteht aus zwei hochs und zwei
teams solche vierer druck felder sind
oft sehr stabil aber trotzdem kommt bei
uns jetzt mal ein bisschen bewegung ins
wetter das sehen sie hier dieser kleinen
kaltfront von dem tief ulrich die
streift uns nämlich morgen im norden und
überquert norddeutschland das tief am
zentralen mittelmeer das schwächelt
jetzt endlich mal das hält sich da ja
schon fast zehn tage es ist diese kleine
kalt von die morgen hier von der
nordseeküste über dänemark und weiter in
richtung polen zieht und uns ein kleines
bisschen regen mitbringt wir sind ja
früher über alles was ich mal beim
wetter ändert es gab ja heute schon
einige sonnige fenster hier zum beispiel
im erzgebirge und auch in berlin kammer
kurz die sonne zum vorschein was sich
hier allerdings sehen was aussieht wie
eine wolken lücke ist in wirklichkeit
nur die hohe bewölkung die einen
schatten wirft auf die hochnebel
obergrenze bei temperaturen heute
übrigens von vier bis elf grad und jetzt
in der nacht sinken die werte an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee an der ems
und am rhein auf 5 grad kälter wird es
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen mit 1
grad dort kann es also für frost reichen
und auch für strassen blätter werde es
gibt immer noch nebel auch bodennebel es
gibt ein bisschen nieselregen dann
wird's gefährlich glatt auf den straßen
und von nordwesten kommt schon die
kaltfront heran wie breitet sich morgen
weiter richtung südosten aus dahinter
lockern die wolken auf es zeigt sich die
sonne bei temperaturen bei fünf bis elf
grad und in den nächsten tagen geht das
ganz ähnlich weiter guten abend